hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
with the return of adorkable rates uh-oh
she's back people raided kicked names
and take you ass Oh name that movie
Justice League so we're gonna watch
today this honest trailer is Japanese
spider-man I'm so excited so we were at
the Mary Poppins return the screening
yesterday and jte over a screen junkies
was there and he was saying you gotta
watch this on his trail he's he's like
I've never seen this show but I'm
telling you you just gotta watch this on
his trail alright fun we'll do it before
we do that Rachel yes tell him about
this Kickstarter you were seduced he was
telling me about in my ear yeah I work
with a company called sua's all for
those of you who don't know I'm a
puppeteer and I we've been working with
Suazo for the past five years as a
puppeteer doing shows with them and
right now Suazo has a kick started going
on for a Christmas book that they want
to put out next year called Merry
Christmas Krampus for those of you who
don't know Krampus is a folklore
character who brings cold all the kids
it's originally from Europe it's a
children's book based on that and it's
really cute and adorable they're doing
it with these movable puppets putting
faces on there's a whole video on it if
you want to contribute to the
Kickstarter link is down below please
contribute anything helps really and so
far we are on our way to making quite a
bit please go ahead and contribute any
like I said and anything caps anything
is helpful help them make more people
let's learn what Japanese spider-man is
Japanese I'm spider-man like to my
favorite things the whole world I'm so
excited
yes Japanese is one of my favorite
things by Domino's so by the man scuse
me sir by the man this trailer is for us
that's cool
[Music]
I did not know this was everything oh
gosh yes equip a clip licensing deal
between Marvel Comics and toy a comes a
loose adaptation of the webslinger like
very loose motocross racer with the
enchanted blood of a dying alien from
Planet spider planet night a car that
docks into a giant robot it's like
American spider-man if all the wins nine
wish for Peter was to become a Punisher
[Music]
[Laughter]
Power Rangers where every episode as our
hero transforming after yelling into a
handheld applies
but since Japanese spider-man actually
came out first
yeah I can say the Megazord is actually
just a cheap ripoff of real part of ah
but still you know good say it pip
tire of CGI special effects we turn to a
time when all they had to work with was
a rope in a dream where the monster of
the week was made at a pursuit in
garbage basic gymnastics with Luke to
make the board impressive and the same
back I keep getting reviews because
someone stole the suit we can print up
shooter put Japanese spider-man on the
case so yourself without super hero
patina enjoy a fresh take on the
character that may not be the strongest
[Music]
a man face got about that sure
[Laughter]
Oh
Zooey's how the seven days and oh yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh very men's now guys what zone you're
doing were you later bye mama
[Music]
oh my what
[Music]
a KA my life holy moly good job John
Bailey and I just saw him the other day
- good job John Bailey I just saw him on
yesterday he's actually in the bumblebee
movie - yeah I know I'm so excited about
that I haven't seen it good job writers
of honest trailers holy crap thank you
for introducing them oh man
I really respect you guys for going way
out of your way to binge-watch in the
seventies I know it's show that they
went up to episode like 40 something to
do the TV show was there a daunting test
for them because they have to watch all
of them I imagine they they're probably
try to prep something for into the
spider-verse so some other spider-man
movie and then they ended up let's do
the Japanese spider-man what I really
like to try to do my own honest trailers
commentary take on this but normally I
avoid the honest trailers if I haven't
seen this the material they're covering
right it's a movie I haven't seen I'm
like there's gonna be spoilers so I'm
not gonna watch it I'll be really gonna
watch that I don't want many spoilers to
be had I mean it's gonna be silly and
ridiculous well this goes to show you
that Asian people can also play our
famous Marvel heroes so we can have
Asian actors be in there as long as you
change the entire source material there
is nothing the only resemblance is some
web slinging crawling and and a Spider
Man suit other than that this is like
not spider-man
at all I mean the suit doesn't even fit
him properly it looks like Spencer's
Outfitters yeah whoa cool factor to
alert though is how so much of this show
did everything before the Power Rangers
with an average is the iconic ones I
forget what these are called but the
whole giant robot thing I mean like the
Megazords from the yeah I mean gun domes
have been around since like the eighties
/ 78 I think they've been doing that
stuff for a long time I think just a lot
of people could think that that came
from Power Rangers because that's what
we affiliated our childhood with you
know we saw that stuff when we were kids
but no that stuff's actually been around
for a long time in Japan I think we got
a do an adaptation of this spider I
think now that we have the spider verse
coming out we need I would have put it
past them yeah by for Phil Lord and
Chris Miller right that I wouldn't be
surprised if they had like a little
Easter egg even if it was like a second
I know that we were able to notice it
that would be so no I'm going through
though tomorrow this looks awesome
I'm I I'm I watch a few episodes these
days I don't know where machine gun
shooting people or you know there's so
many streaming sites these days you
never know maybe this is available
somewhere and is ill origin and
reasoning like he's not Peter Parker
he's just some other dude with some
vengeful mission I know any chance you
like I think it's hilarious
I've never seen in a spider-man anything
you know he's always like just putting
the suit on and then he just goes but
here it's like spider whatever whatever
like this is my favorite honest trailers
this is great I've never been introduced
to something so honest trailers is one
of my favorites thank you guys for all
your hard work on this one is amazing
it's amazing it's me
I wanted to give a patron of the day
shoutout before this video and so man
named Mikhail Linden our beautiful man
from Sweden recently I was asking him
about like hey can you educate me on
some other cultures like what Christmas
tradition is it figures learning much
Japanese spider-man why not shout out
Sweden right they're connected sure they
haven't talked about Krampus yeah this
is all connected it's one giant universe
and he was talking about Jill Scylla
thing named didn't and Jill bored and
Lucia and gelatin I don't even know if I
said those words right but I just want
to say thank you so much for educating
me is so much on these awesome Christmas
traditions it really seems like the
Swedish people know how to live it up so
much better than us Americans oh they're
great they've got great songs too
there's the one that goes it's really
cute you know there's more to Mikhail
than just him being Swedish are you sure
he has a three-week vacation oh no it's
good for you
he's gonna do Swedish things nice love
you Mikhail a farmer feature page homie
thanks dude all right you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification beli check us on
patreon and also make sure to check out
that Kickstarter that Rachel's talking
about the beginning this video much love